[Musica]
creare ponti affettivi per colmare le
differenze non avrei mai pensato che un
giorno sarei stato qui a raccontarlo è
[Musica]
probabilmente sono arrivata questo
processo perché
da bambina come tutti ho subito come
tutti ho come molti ho subito delle
emarginazioni delle esclusioni era una
bambina del centro italia con i genitori
del centro italia che si trasferisce al
nord e quindi
in un periodo politicamente
abbastanza
determinante è stata la nascita della
lega lombarda e io mi trovavo proprio lì
in quel momento scurissima di carnagione
un po come un calimero con genitori
meridionali e che erano pure punk e mi
trovo quindi un po emarginata da dal
contesto più classico di questo paesino
della provincia bresciana
ecco io penso che ve l'ho raccontato
perché penso che dagli arrivi tanto di
quello che io oggi faccio come artista e
come persona che ormai sono due cose che
non si possono più separare e
sicuramente questa sofferenza è stata la
grazie a questa sofferenza sono riuscita
a trasformare tutto questo mondo in un
linguaggio d'arte e per questo oggi
ci sono dei temi fondamentali
nella mia poetica nella mia arte che
sicuramente sono dei valori che sono
valori come inclusione memoria
compassione e democrazia e anche appunto
non creare dei ponti affettivi
ho pensato a delle opere per parlarvi di
questi valori per vederli veramente
attualizzati nelle opere e ho pensato
dei lavori ce ne sono tanti quasi tutte
le mie opere hanno queste tematiche
all'interno ma alcune probabilmente sono
più evidenti di altre la prima opera di
cui vi volevo parlare wormholes che è
un'opera teo realizzato tra il 2014 2015
a new york dopo essere stata invitata a
lei essi piste tutto curatorial program
di new york o
ho ricevuto un altro invito è infatti a
isp e museo dello stress si univano per
dare vita a un nuovo progetto e questo
progetto
in questo progetto mi chiedevano di dar
vita a un'opera collettiva nel quartiere
di win sgorga new york
in particolare il museo dello stress si
occupava di famiglie hispanic le
famiglie più povere ispaniche quindi
avevano accesso supermercati avevano
accesso a signor center e dato che io da
bambina un po triste e un po insomma
esclusa portata dietro una lettera
d'amore che mia nonna
aveva scritto mio nonno mentre era al
fronte ho deciso di partire con i nonni
del quartiere al signor center e di
chiedervi proprio le storie d'amore è
stata un'esperienza bellissima
la maggior parte delle storie erano in
spagnolo ma ce n'erano anche molte in
americano alcune in francese 2 italiano
ovviamente tra le quali quella di mia
nonna
perché vi parlo di questo lavoro perché
prima vi ho parlato di un valore
importante per me che è la memoria la
memoria
qui l'ho vista attualizzata benissimo
perché ho inserito queste storie
all'interno di un muro una parete quando
entravo in questo spazio dove esponevo
vedevi una parete qualsiasi invece se ti
appoggiavi sentivi sussurrate tutte le
storie d'amore del quartiere quindi in
parti diverse della parete tu potevi
sentire queste storie d'amore
la cosa più bella fu quando i nonni
vennero con i propri figli propri nipoti
e riascoltare le proprie storie d'amore
questa per me è stata una delle opere
meglio riuscite che ne ha veramente
suscitato una grande commozione
poi vi voglio parlare di un altro lavoro
che ha a che fare strettamente con il
tema della memoria che è
la vita una ruota un lavoro più recente
del 2018 e mi hanno fatto questi in
video a nella zona centrale storica di
roma a campo dei fiori
e ho conosciuto mario fiorentini mario
fiorentini un gappista partigiano che
oggi a 104 anni io l'ho conosciuto che
ne aveva 102 lucidissimo e ha una mente
veramente
originale
mario mi hai raccontato molte delle sue
azioni delle sue azioni dada pista a lui
e la sua compagna e tutti gli altri
gappisti che erano quelli che
difendevano diciamo da nell'invasione
fascista l'italia decidono di far delle
azioni in particolare in quel momento
c'erano saragat e pertini nel carcere di
regina coeli mario butta una bomba nel
carcere di regina coeli e scappa riesce
indenne da questo da questa fuga perché
ho scelto questa tra le tante che mario
mi ha raccontato perché dopo questo 26
dicembre del 43 data nella quale lui
fece questa fuga questa azione veterano
l'utilizzo delle biciclette a roma ed è
una cosa molto importante perché per
ottenere una bicicletta una famiglia
doveva lavorare almeno un anno quindi
vietare l'utilizzo della bicicletta era
tagliare le gambe letteralmente alle
persone
e dato che io sono una ciclista mi viene
in mente anche un diritto che dopo il v
per scontato quanto invece è stato
lottato sudato
ricordiamoci che rare un momento storico
in cui bartali la bicicletta veniva
utilizzata come mezzo rivoluzionario e
bartali nascondeva nella sua canna della
bicicletta i messaggi partigiani
è stato molto bello poi alla fine ci
tengo a dirlo la performance nella
performance infatti mario in piazza è
venuto a vedere proprio è venuto a
vedere il proprio video io nei panni di
mario e poi ha dato vita a un racconto
molto molto forte molto bello
vi voglio parlare di altri lavori
ero figlia unica tutti con me con voi è
il sottotitolo è un lavoro cui tengo
tantissimo
mi vede immersa dal 2012 alla ricerca di
nuclei familiari
nei quali mi inserisco per fare una
fotografia di famiglia
mi vedrò cambiare all'interno di questi
nuclei familiari perché sono partita nel
2012 ed è un progetto che voglio fare
per tutta la mia vita quindi prima
figlia può essere la poesia poi nonna
chi lo sa
in questo caso ve ne parlo perché
sicuramente si parla di memoria sia per
come la composizione della fotografia
viene fatta che ormai è obsoleto fare
una fotografia di famiglia e sia perché
crea veramente dei ponti con tutte
quelle memorie collettive che ci sono
anche all'interno della famiglia
dopo questo passo a un lavoro molto
diverso scusate se la carrellata lunga
questa è una fotografia dove sono
inserito una famiglia di circo ad
esempio ed è stato molto bello perché a
volte ho vissuto veramente di periodi
molto intensi e insieme a loro molto
perché loro insieme ad aprirmi loro
armadi dato che mi danno i loro gioielli
di famiglia e loro abiti mi apro non
proprio letteralmente anche loro cuori
quindi io da perfetta sconosciuta un
attimo dopo diventò veramente parte del
di quella famiglia in punta di piedi mi
raccomando
adesso vi voglio parlare di un'altra
serie di lavori che sono i miei cimiteri
per insetti anche questi li realizzo dal
2008 il primo realizzato la fondazione
spinola banna torino questo che vediamo
invece al museo pan di napoli e mi piace
tantissimo questo scatto perché
quando i bambini si commuovono di fronte
a un'opera vuol dire che un qualcosina
si è riuscito a comunicare è un po un
gioco come quello che fanno i bambini
però l'ho fatto da grande e e ve ne
parlo perché abbia parlato di democrazia
prima e di compassione sicuramente
questo lavoro contiene questi elementi
infatti viene dedicato a
degli esseri
degli individui che non sono esseri
umani una sepoltura
anche per loro e non vuole essere
sicuramente un tema
mortifero ma i miei cimiteri per insetti
sprizzano allegri energia da tutte le
parti proprio perché più che altro
vogliono ragionare sul tema sul ciclo
vita e morte che è un tema che va
affrontato per poi arrivare all'ultimo
che ho realizzato
e qui siamo sul lungo tevere sotto
castel sant'angelo a roma e questa volta
il mio cimitero galleggiante e ho avuto
questa visione esattamente così quindi
una camera d'aria che è stato
difficilissimo trovare perché ormai non
esistono più le camere d'aria e è
posizionato in mezzo a castel
sant'angelo era visitabile grazie a una
pilotina quindi grazie a una pilotina le
persone potevano attraversare il fiume e
circumnavigare l'opera è stato molto
bello perché al di là delle aspettative
i racconti e le restituzioni che mi sono
arrivate sono state al di fuori di
quello che mi potessi immaginare
mi hanno rievocato riti sul gange e
tantissime sensibilità e tra l'altro
dovevano essere sì 7 pilotina da 10
persone ciascuna invece sono diventata e
70 perché la gente era veramente
contenta di andare a visitare questo
cimiterino in mezzo a
lungotevere
e poi vi voglio parlare del non per
importanza dei miei ricami per ultimi ma
vi voglio parlare dei neri cani perché
sono quelli che mi consentono di
sedimentare tutte queste esperienze
quindi io faccio esperienze azioni in
prima persona
creo cerco storie le persone mi donano
le loro storie ogni volta queste storie
rimangono dentro di me io ho bisogno di
di restituirle di farle uscire e ho
scelto la carta e ricamo nonostante la
piccola fosse la bambina in falegnameria
dal nonno poi crescendo ho scoperto che
questo gesto simbolico anche rispetto
quello che facevo io con le storie delle
persone quindi creare ponti affettivi
con persone con esseri viventi di
qualsiasi natura era esattamente quello
che il filo poteva fare quindi cucire
tutto il mondo in un'unica grande tela
i soggetti sono molto diversi fra loro
spesso
riflettono proprio su su quelle forme
invisibili
su quelle forme invisibili d'affetto di
scambio e
e
poi c'è coccinelle che ad esempio mi
aiuta a farvi capire come più immagini
messe uno vicino all'altro possono
restituire un senso di totalità
terrestre perché in ogni piccolo vale
cioè raccontata una storia ma mettendo
le tutte assieme c'è proprio quella
connessione di cui vi parlavo prima il
mio augurio quindi rimane quello di
non dico di non essere digitalizzati
l'adige lottizzazione molto importante
anche se non riesco nemmeno a dirlo
però è importantissimo che noi capiamo
dove stiamo andando e quindi per capire
dove stiamo andando penso che siano
fondamentali il mantenimento di alcuni
lavori e ci portiamo possiamo divertire
l'arte permette questa trasformazione
e io ne sono testimone
sono contentissima oggi di avere questo
linguaggio e spero che diventi sempre
più universale
[Applauso]